With the Android system "Lollipop" ..
The "multidimensional design" differs from the way applications look,
To create more magical moments.
But the devices that run older versions of Android,
You do not have all those features.
I'm Joanna Smith, and one of the best things ...
The multi-dimensional design given to us is "toolbars".
Which are now more magical, because they have become so convenient to go back.
The toolbar is a richer and more flexible viewing mode than the traditional process bar.
In fact, toolbars are part of the display hierarchy.
It can move, or even interact with scrolling "pass options".
As a viewing method, you can use toolbars.
As a standalone element anywhere in the application.
To give the user options, controls,
Without having to display the design model at its widest at the top of the screen.
You can also make multiple toolbars,
If the application structure depends on the design content,
Or if you grant the user a lot of controls.
To provide the toolbar with instructions and choices,
You can switch the menu to a toolbar,
To display those instructions to the user.
You can also make your own controls,
Such as to use a button to return to the top level.
Because you can use toolbars anywhere in your design,
You can also choose to use the toolbar instead of the Help bar.
Simply put, the more you need to control
Giving you the appearance and function of the traditional help bar.
If, in order to use the toolbar, instead of the normal Help bar,
The Help bar should first stop working,
The easiest way to do this is ..
You can extend the theme from: "theme.AppCompat.NoActionBar"
Or one of its other variants.
Then make the toolbar the same as any other design in your app.
Set the Help Bar to customize
When he or she passes a particular activity or part.
In doing so,
The system adds "Standard" Help bar options for you,
So you do not need to fill the list yourself.
Now you may be convinced how distinctive these "toolbars" are.
But how you use them in versions of your app,
Targeting the older SDKs.
Well, toolbars have been added
To the support library for "AppCompat V21".
And now it has become easy
"Setting Support for the Help Bar" instead of "Adjusting the Help Bar"
To replace the Help bar in older devices
See "Explanation" for more support options available,
So you can bring more magical moments to users.
For more tips on making sure your app is at its best,
Check out our rest of our Android development themes
Or consider joining our community on Google+
But the most important is ..
Just continue to create better applications.